mais 100 200 le tai chi bille en tête
avec lequel le questionnaire de
pédéraste notoire rappelle le suis aussi
[Musique]
première question marcel de son prénom
rouste deux ans
quel est pour toi le comble misère
il
passé inaperçu moi j'aurais dit absence
de papier cul c'est moi qui fais le test
à une seconde question le projet voilà
tu vivre à las vegas parce que parce que
j'y ai passé une semaine génial que je
me dis comme partout je me suis fait
chier je me dis que la saga ça serait
bien
tu peux a fait chier avec l'âge j'ai
joué wen a flambé pas beaucoup vu que
j'avais pas trop de thunes mais c'était
marrant djermakoye batista pas de tu
n'as tu leur gestion c'est pas grave
j'ai pas perdu beaucoup
les couches minces et ton idéal de
bonheur puis à page
je dois pour novembre puisque je m'en
mets en partout mais avec du fric en
fait soumettre obligés de travailler
quoi n'importe quoi tu adores battu
tenue avec un ben oui mais ceux avec qui
je me maquille sans jamais de blé alors
c'est mal
il n'essaie pas de gros buzz mais les
beaux gosses il s'attend forcément plein
de trous pour quelle faute tu plus
d'indulgence
on habite ici parce qu'elle a tellement
que je suis obligée de me faire répondre
moi je réduis faut que leur tour quels
sont les héros de romans que tu préfères
difficile j'ai jamais rien eu on a
vraiment une bonne chose si vous mettrez
mais presque
non je n'ai pas de héros de romans dé
000 pointé vers l'infini ton peintre
favori numéro de francis bacon que la
qualité préféré je suis là
qui loue sa gueule quand elle embrouille
personnellement que soit mon téléphone
et j'ai à faire
je sais pas j'aime pas trop les femmes
et je m'en fous la qualité est une femme
et qu'elle était qu'est-ce que tu es
meilleur en toi je suis gentil
le wisla pour moi j'ai pas entendu des
ulis la magie tels que des cieux mais
c'est aussi là que dans les occupations
préférées plus facile parce que ça j'en
ai pas d occupation préfère discuter
il suffit que tu vois toute la journée
ben je m'emmerde souvent je suis maire
je sais pas manger la grosse poignée
ben non non non ça va ça qui aurait tué
m je n'étais pas béatrice dalle
c'est pas que je suis contente d'être
mois mais personne d'autre non plus
n'ont pas si pas défaut
l'américain
je suis jaloux c'est pas avec plein de
choses même si c'est un défaut parce que
ça me prend la tête à moi ben si aussi
mais ça la limite c'est moins grave mais
ça me prend la tête à moi non tu te
payes tu oses pas des fous
ça me rend triste quel serait ton plus
grand malheur
e
être obligé d'avoir un travail tous les
jours
x passe ou à la couleur que tu préfères
rbb j'aime bien zerbib est il mal être
et il est maintenant quand vous voulez
j'aurais dit kaka doigt parce que ça
sonne mieux le don de la nature que tu
aimerais avoir
je suis très bien comme ça alors
finalement ça va quoi jouer de la
musique quoi tient ça dans la nature ça
va brasser ben moi c'est faire caca sans
odeur assez classe comment aimerais tu
mourir j'aime pas mourir ça va la tête
je ne sais pas je me suis pas posé la
question j'ai pas du tout aucun plaisir
à mourir moi je l'aimerais mourir vision
the last one quelle est l'étape est en
tournée ce prix présent présence ou un
chrono présent je pense à bas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou